inflation this is not an economics class
so you're going to get a simplified
version of this but you don't need to
necessarily need to know all the ins and
outs and details to understand basically
what's going on what is inflation you're
looking at it this is a photo from I
believe it's from the young I believe
it's from the nineteen nineties okay
which is why the young why the
resolution is not fantastic okay those
of you who maybe don't pay all that much
attention okay this is unleaded petrol
which is kind of like the standard
petrol and it's going for yeah eighteen
point nine cents per litre right now
this was a very very noble price back in
the nineties I remember reading is
Philip petrol the first time I started
driving my car and these are the kinds
of prices that are we expected of course
this is not the kind of thing we
encounter today we can't these more like
this stowing yeah this is actually sadly
not that unusual like people do not even
bat an eyelid now if they see a price
like this you probably would try to
avoid it but you know what if you're
kind of stuck you're just gonna do it
right that's just the price of petrol
now okay it's so much an accepted part
of things that now this was a photo from
actual oscillators you know this is a
photo from I think it was late last year
and you can see there are quite a few
people who are interested in getting
this petrol station because they're all
like OMG it's less than a dollar that's
amazing I have got remember the last
time I saw control that cheap okay so
what you're looking at here is just one
particular example of inflation here so
one sentence definition for you right
what is inflation generally speaking
it's the increase in price of consumer
goods and services
right so broadly speaking anything you
pay the GST on goods and services
generally speaking these are all
increasing in price it's important that
you note this because this knife here
other things do increase in price we've
looked at some examples before and then
I'm not consumer goods and services they
increase in price but that's not
inflation so for example we've talked
about shares right and investments and
real estate those things increase in
price - but that's not inflation that's
more like stuff and other forces like
that so generally speaking as you've
seen with petrels one easy visible
example things increase in price over
time right over a number of years did
you get more expensive now this really
for me this is the the number of a
puppet for business that's what it is
but what I really want to know is why
like what causes this okay like if you
don't care about my business deep it
sort of affects my money day to day
honor or non then maybe this I'm gonna
give you two simplified reasons why why
impatient exists and they're not tell
you some reasons like done as well okay
so I've got one two dot points I'm gonna
name them and then I'm gonna explain
them for you okay so number one is what
we call a way home it's the window-seat
commodity commodity supply okay so for
those of you who don't become
astronautics before you ran out the two
most important words in all their
clothes are supply and demand right so
this is just one half of it commodity
supply refers to the fact that well if
stuff is being used up like saying
fossil fuels right that means that over
time business and this illicit right so
if there's less stuff right if it's
harder to find something like this less
of it around in the world that means you
have to work harder to get it that means
you can charge people more for so less
stuff is more valuable does that
make sense like when something is scarce
like you know every the reason why
precious metals are precious is not just
because like you can do you can they
look pretty and all that kind of thing
but there's not that much of it right
there's like sand everywhere you know
any place you go you can find sand so it
doesn't cost very much gold though you
go deep you gonna blow up the ground to
find it there's less of it so it's more
value does that make sense so that has
to do with how much of the stuff that
there is okay so there's the first
reason why over time there's less stuff
so okay there's one more big part of it
it's not just how much of the stuff in
it but how much money there is to buy
this stuff okay money supply now
basically the idea is governments
governments spend sorry not spin
governments print money all the time
haha tjj all goes $5 my daughter bits
print money constantly
okay now daughters are a quick question
why the government's everyday all rather
long why are they printing more money
okay all right so so first first reason
might be okay we need more money okay
yeah it's a sad moment with your 16 year
old student have been way than you do
when you need more that's that's an
obvious one but why would you need more
money like why did yeah okay no this is
interesting right sir
yeah okay so this is again I'm not going
to get into all of the degree details
okay but here Rick what I said that what
causes it what causes inflation and the
answer is more money in the system
causes it not the other way around
it's not like we say Oh stuff is getting
more expensive I've been a print or
money it's the other way we print more
money and figure out of this way right
yes very good if you've got more money
right yeah I think this is what you're
getting at if there's more money in
circulation then all of that money is
less valuable
so that actually comes back to our
original question well then why did I do
it I'll give you two reasons
number one it's not so much in our
country as say in the US but money
doesn't last forever right like money
gets damaged and it needs to be replaced
and so on okay
plastic money's incredible incredibly
durable which is great us money it's all
made of iPod
exactly and you know how people make you
to read anyway so so number one number
one government's pretty money they
increase the money supply because they
need to replace it
secondly it actually saw to replace
replace currency really but also another
thing that printing more money does is
it drives economic growth now this is
I'm gonna cross over this really upset
at me being sophistical about this but
it's not that complicated to understand
just think about it this way imagine if
imagine you the amount of money in a
country just completely stay put like it
was a lot it was frozen okay so it's
like suppose these five dollars are all
of the dollars that exist in this
country
okay and no one's gonna have any more
okay um people are working they are
blowing up the ground and getting stuff
out of the ground they're making value
we call the gross domestic product GDP
if you've heard this letters before okay
so overall our country's becoming more
and more valuable as a country as people
but there's still only five dollars
right so therefore this five dollars
which represents all of the money into
the country is now incredibly valuable
in case in fact every day this five
dollars is gonna get more and more
valuable this represents the entire
country's finances right so you'd expect
because our country is growing and like
making new industries and you know with
babies and there's more population what
people are gonna do stuff this is going
to increase in value over time okay so
if you're me and you have in your hot
little hands the five dollars that's
everyone's money in the world and it's
getting up in the country it's getting
more and more bad where every day what
are you gonna do with this five dollars
you are not going to spend it because
the longer you hold on to it the more
valuable it is right so therefore he's
what numbers do they say you know what
we do we don't want people to do this we
don't want people to take money and just
you know stick it underneath their beds
okay we actually want them to spend
money that's that's what drives economic
growth so if we print more money the
money would be less and less valuable
over time which makes people do what
spend it because if you wait you're just
gonna lose out right that money
underneath your bed is to keep it less
and less valuable well what people
didn't do stuff that's why this stuff
like um if you've a few guys are old
enough to know about like government
stimulus packages so like sometimes the
government's like holy cow the economy
slowing down we'd better just give
everyone money right how many how many
years ago maybe seven or eight years ago
the government gave everyone like five
hundred dollars just like here you go
have five hundred dollars and suspend it
that's the important thing if it doesn't
get spent if it just sits in someone's
bank account or in someone's pocket
it doesn't Drive anything so let's just
support what is inflation it's that
stuff gets more expensive but there are
reasons for that okay now not everything
by the way not everything and it stayed
in someone's bank account then yes it
would say is nothing would change okay
however if I think go to like some of
your pen to coffee shop right and then I
suspend well I buy a lot of coffee I
spent that five hundred dollars that's
going into someone's that's actually
going into that business it's growing
it's gonna go into wages salaries etc
it's gonna it's gonna it's sort of like
oiling and boiling the gears of the
system right it's going to bring revenue
to the government because so it just
sort of good round and round around it's
making stuff happen okay just think
about the opposite of this right suppose
everyone just stayed home and no one
bought anything okay so you might think
ah well look if money just goes round in
circles right like it's it's in my
pocket or it's in the hands of the
person who owns the cafe what does it
matter well the opposite of it is if
money just stays put if no one goes to
the shops no he goes to store those
businesses
close the businesses can't survive it's
the movement of money it's that
circulation that makes it you know birth
right so even though you would think art
is a net gain of nothing if all money is
doing is changing hands the changing
hands is what drives economic growth
that's why this trade and that's my
trade magazine okay now um yeah he's my
counter example okay um we've got things
that are inflating costs but not
everything does this is a memory stick
it's actually a picture of a bear see I
bought about would anyone like to hazard
a guess as to how much it cost me to buy
this 14 years ago my dolls too close
yeah about 60 I can tell you in my in my
year 11 what little hands
I had to part with one hundred and
eighty dollars which I've saved up for
for like oh yeah right
I had to part with this to get that
because I bought a limited edition
camera and all I came with was four
megabytes of RAM so I wanted to take
more photos and that's why I bought this
and yeah my parents were like are you
serious it's just like this tiny plus a
bit of thing yeah okay so so so this is
something you can get now right I should
point out it's much smaller like it
pretty much just goes in your computer
and this almost nothing sticking up okay
this today I went and looked it up will
cost you 105 dollars that's a fair chunk
of money but just compare for a second
how much bigger is this versus this it's
about a thousand times bigger little
warm okay and you just have a look at
the price differential right had I
bought that amount of storage back then
because it's a thousand times bigger it
would have cost me a thousand times more
okay so what's going on what happened to
it
I thought stop we're spending more it's
easy to me so have a look I can eat two
reasons here right I've given you two
reasons number one money supply number
two commodity supply money supply what's
happened to money supply over the last
fourteen years
just look what's becoming is more money
right so that should mean this stuff
gets less valuable so the only way at
least in this skin things could change
is up here right what's happened to this
stuff now this you can like just go to
loss property and find ten of adhesive
right yeah they're everywhere as a cure
just mentioned they're cheaper to
manufacture because now China has like
thousands of factories that are popping
these things out so they're everywhere
so they are less valuable more start
less valuable so therefore that's all of
the UM that's all the logic behind it
very simply I had a couple of bone
okay now just really simply really
simply inflation because it's just like
the same idea of increasing price we
have another kind of thing under this
topic that we describe when something
starts at a set value and increases but
it's for a completely different reason
right we call it interest right what is
interested what is interesting it has
it's very very different from this yeah
okay the the bank that you give money to
they're going to pay you the little bits
because they get to use your money for a
little while right so in some ways this
and this are like Eastern West they're
completely different economic principles
okay but and this is not a power
battement the same thing is happening
underneath that's why there's no
inflation formula on your formula sheet
because the inflation formula starts
with some we want to work out the amount
that something to be worth you start
with some initial value and it's going
to increase by some rate for some number
of months years days you know what that
formula is it's the interest right
compound interest and inflation that
mathematics is the same okay so that's
why we don't like that's not a fear of
mathematics it reveals that all these
kinds of things